what I have been a veteran of the World
Economic Forum summit and I've been
going to Davos for the last 21 years and
I've been participating in the india
summit and being one of its hose for the
fast ferry one here it's a special
occasion that India economic summit has
moved outside Delhi and it is now
started engagement with the states and I
think this is this is going to auger
very well this is going to expand the
understanding of states or what the
international community wants and what
the international community once it can
express to those at the state level
where the next level of reform and the
real level of decision-making is